hey guys Pete here Westworld season 1
episode 2 came out early on the HBO
streaming services this week so I wanted
to go ahead and get my recap and review
out right away if you're not familiar
with my episode reviews I do them in two
parts the first part of the video is a
scene-by-scene recap and where I go over
everything that happened and then I do a
review with my thoughts about the
important parts at the end of the video
I put a timestamp link in the
description so you can skip the
scene-by-scene recap and go right to the
summary if you want to if you haven't
watched episode 2 yet this video will
contain spoilers for everything that has
happened in the show up to this point a
ton of cool stuff happened in this
episode so let's jump right into it
episode 2 opens with Dolores in bed we
hear a Bernard
telling her to wake up and then see her
walk out into the night into her yard as
she looks out at the horizon we hear
bernard say do you remember we see a
luxury train arrive in a station with
two newcomers getting off the first
character we know from the trailers is
named william and we see him approached
by a woman we think is a host as soon as
he gets off the train she says since
it's his first time that she needs to
ask him some questions
if you happen to play around with the
dulles Incorporated site before the show
came out you probably noticed the
questions were the same ones they asked
when you're planning to sign up for your
trip we've learned a few things from
their conversation to keep in mind for
later she tells him that the only limit
in Westworld is you're in the
imagination and that you start out in
the middle of the park where things are
simple and safe the further out you
adventure the more intense the
experience gets how far you want to go
is entirely up to you
they go into a room or whether it has
clothes and weapons he asked if there is
an orientation and she answers there is
no orientation or guidebook figuring out
how things work is part of the fun she
realizes he is wondering if she is a
host or a real person and prompts him to
ask when he does she answers if you
can't tell the difference then why does
it matter he looks at a case of handguns
and asks if those are real she says that
they're real enough but you can't kill
anyone you aren't supposed to he picks
out some clothes and asked if there's a
changing room this leads to another
interesting exchange where she tells him
that she can help him change or if he
wants or prefers and she could step
outside he asked
what do most people do and she responds
you don't have to worry what most people
do she starts to unbutton his shirt and
he says that he understands she then
asks if he really understands and she
says that all the hosts are here for you
myself included she moved him close to
say they can stay there for a while but
he passed his saying he doesn't want to
keep his friend waiting next we visit
the underground West world programming
division where Bernard is talking to
Elsie she's looking at Abernathy Delores
his father from the first episode trying
to figure out what went wrong she says
she thinks there's something [ __ ] up
with his cognition and that she thinks
Bernard feels exactly the same way she's
basically saying that when he saw the
photo he didn't glitch out right at that
point that he actually mulled it over to
work his way back through memories this
isn't supposed to happen since the hosts
have their memories wiped at the end of
each day they agree that they know where
the error originated and else he adds
that Bernard had covered for dr. Forge
he wants him to let her rebuild
Abernathy but he won't let her go
against the policy she then asked to
look into hosts who had contact with him
and mentions Dolores specifically he
says that she has been examined and
cleared and that else you should leave
it alone the main takeaway here is that
she thinks what happened to Abernathy
could be contagious if it wasn't just a
dissonant episode we see Dolores going
through her normal routine but then she
stops all of a sudden and she looks out
at the street she remembers a violent
scene with dead hosts everywhere laying
on the ground
she zones out until mave ask her to move
on from in front of the brothel before
she leaves she turns and says these
violent delights have violent ends the
same thing that Abernathy told her in
the previous episode Maeve looks
perplexed and the scene ends with a shot
where we wonder what she's thinking
William comes out and his cowboy gear
and the host tells him there's one more
thing he has a choice between being a
white hat or a black hat if you're not
clear what this is about there's a
gaming aspect to Westworld so you can
either play it as a good guy or a bad
guy
William chooses to be a white hat which
we can assume means that he'll be like
stopping host from doing bad things
rather than the other way around at this
point we realize that it doesn't matter
which side you choose because you'll
always come out on
regardless he passes through a door at
the end of the hallway which looks like
a saloon the bartender pours him a drink
and we see Logan walking through a door
on the opposite side since his friend
has been there before he tells him that
he probably thinks he knows what's going
to happen but that he really has no idea
William asks how they get to the park
and at the same time he realized they're
in a train that starts to move Logan
says that Westworld seduces everyone's
minds and that he will be begging him to
stay before all said and done he says
that this place is the answer to that
question you've been asking who you
really are
Logan tells William he can't wait to see
who that person is and then the scene
ends next we see a man who is about to
be hung there's a man wearing a badge
and he's announcing the charges and we
see the man in black ride up on a horse
he tells the sheriff he needs to have a
word with the man he wants to hang and
the disagreement ensues the man in black
ends up killing the sheriff and all his
men to free the condemned man from the
gallows he hands him the scalp with the
maize on it that we saw up from episode
1 and tells him that this is a part of
the deepest level of the game the host
doesn't act like he knows what it is and
the man in black takes off pulling him
along with the rope that's been tied
around his neck mavis in the saloon
where she sees a newcomer come in she
takes him to sit down and starts to tell
him a story about a voice in her head
that kept her from doing the things that
she always wanted to do she says she
went somewhere across the sea where we
assumed things would change but then she
starts to think about a violent
encounter and stops talking we next see
her in the programming center with the
tech checking her out when asked she
gives the right answer of this is the
new world and in this world you can be
whatever the [ __ ] you want to be which
prompts him to say there's nothing wrong
with her we hear a woman's voice say
that she will be decommissioned if they
don't get her numbers up she says to
increase her aggression by 20% she's a
hooker so there's no need to be coy she
says if that doesn't work they will send
her to behavior to have them take care
of it we get another shot of the
programming signer to see a new host
being created we see dr. Ford walking
into room where Bernard is sitting
thinking he tells for they can
decommission the two hosts in question
and that he taught him how to make them
but not how hard it is to turn them off
for says he knows something else is
bothering him so
tells him that the photo alone couldn't
have caused what happened to Abernathy
Ford asks if he thinks it was sabotage
and he agrees that is the simplest
answer we don't really know if Bernard
believes Ford is the saboteur but we can
imagine that it's in the back of his
mind
Ford gives a nice little speech about
creating life out of chaos and then we
cut to a different scene we see William
and Logan's train pulling into the
station and they make their way into the
center of town they pass a saloon where
Clementine propositions them and then
William stops to try and help with town
drunk type character who falls off a
wagon Logan tells them to keep moving
since they all will be there later and
that they're simply trying to sell them
on a different adventure as they go off
to get a drink we see Dolores staring at
her own reflection in the window we next
see her in the programming center with
Bernard who asked if she remembers their
last conversation he asked if she told
anyone else about their talk to which
she replies of course not you told me
not to he puts her in analysis mode and
asked some basic questions after he
tells her not to tell anyone that
they've been talking she asked if she
did something wrong and he says no he
says that she is different her thinking
which he finds interesting but others
might not feel the same way she asked if
he did something wrong and then he tells
her to erase the interaction from her
eventlog he then tells her to get back
before anyone misses her we see the new
more aggressive maid at the saloon where
she is talking to a female newcomer
she's telling the same story but this
time she is noticeably stepping up her
game this turns out to just freak out
the newcomer who takes off and it
doesn't want to have anything to do with
her she goes to the bar to get a drink
and has a talk with Clementine who tells
her that she's been having nightmares
she tells her how to wake up from a bad
dream and then sends her back to work as
she walks away mafe starts to have her
that have the memory again she looks
affected and her hands start to shake we
see a tech in the program Center telling
Stubbs about the problem Tubbs has the
tech repurposed Clementine for Maeve's
role telling him that she's done it
before when the tech asked what to do
with MAME he says leave her up on the
floor in case anyone wants to take one
more role with her and then have her
decommissioned in the morning Bernard
comes across
Teresa who's having a cigarette she
seems stressed out after talking with
corporate and tells
they better be ready for launch we don't
know exactly what she's talking about
but she adds that she heard they were
still looking into the problem with a
brunette he lies to her and tells her
that the hosts are back to normal making
her think that their there's nothing to
worry about William and Logan are at
dinner and Logan is pointing out how
William is kind of a wimp in his normal
life the town drunk character from
before approaches the table and offers
to take William on a chance of a
lifetime opportunity Logan is annoyed by
this and asked him to leave and when he
won't he ends up stabbing him through
the hand he gets up from the table and
tells William he has worked up a
different appetite before they leave
with NCM partaking in a foursome and cut
over to William who's in the bed in his
bedroom being approached by Clementine
she tells him that if she isn't to his
liking they can find somebody who is and
he responds by saying no you're perfect
he tells her that he has somebody real
waiting for him at home and she says she
understands she tells him real love is
always worth waiting for and then gives
him a kiss goodbye back in the
programming center we see Tech's
developing Indian warriors for a new
storyline
leaves unhappy with one of the new house
and throws a fit telling them to start
over with that character Teresa comes in
to ask about a request he made for 50
additional hosts and tells him that he's
only gonna be able to get 20 more she
asked if Ford approved the new story and
he says that he hasn't weighed in on
things like that for many years we see
Ford getting into an elevator that
brings him up into the park he looks to
be in a deserted area where he is
approached by a boy who asked if he's
lost he says no that he only strayed a
bit too far from where he's supposed to
be he says he imagines that it's the
same thing that happened to the boy and
they strike up a conversation Ford says
he's going to take a walk and invites
the little boy to come along we come
back to the man in black and see that he
is still pulling Lawrence behind this
horse by the hangman's noose around his
neck
Lawrence ask if he knows who he is and
the man in black says of course since
they used to be friends he takes off his
blindfold to reveal that they're at a
cantina the man in black tells him about
different things he knows about him and
says that he never told him he had a
family as he's placing bullets on the
table in front of him a young girl runs
up to the table calling Lawrence Papa
the man in black says this is why he
loves this place the secrets he says
it's better than the real world because
the real world is chaos in West world
every detail adds up to something
Laura
to ask what he wants from him and he
says that maze the man in black gives
his daughter two of the bullets to hold
and says it would be up to him to decide
what they'll do with those later
Lawrence says he doesn't know anything
about a maze so he asks him another time
from there he says he'll have to find a
way to jog his memory and shoots the
bartender standing next to the table
while this is going on when you see
attack watching his progress on a
handheld monitor he approaches stubs to
tell him that the man in black has
already taken out a whole Posse and
asked if he wants him to be slowed down
Stubbs replies that that man gets
whatever he wants back at the canteen
and we see that Lawrence's cousins have
surrounded the man in black he tells him
he has been coming to Westworld for 30
years and in a sense he was born there
he says the confrontation is exactly why
he comes and gets up to take them on he
takes them out in pretty epic fashion
including shooting the last attacker
through a wall he takes a couple other
stragglers out and then asks the girl
for the two bullets he gave her again he
says that Lawrence gets to decide how
he'll use them and we realize he saved
them for the wife and daughter if he
wouldn't tell them where the maze was he
kills the wife first and then the
daughter speaks up to tell him the maze
isn't for him the man in black says he
will take his chances and she tells him
where to go he gives her the last bullet
back and when Lawrence tells him to go
home he says that this time he's never
going back we see Ford and the boy
walking through the desert they look out
onto an empty space which the boy calls
nowhere land Ford asked him if he can't
see the town with the white church and
asked if he can hear this Bell he
listens to hear the sound of a bell and
then a rattlesnake appears it looks like
it's going to strike him until he holds
out his finger and it freezes in place
the boy asked if it was magic that he
used to stop it and Ford replies that
everything in this world is magic except
to the magician he tells the boy he
should run along now and then says
you're not going to come back here again
are you the look on the boy's face
changes when he says no similar to what
we see with Dolores when Bernard tells
her to do things so we kind of get the
idea that maybe he's a host the scene
ends with Ford staring at a small black
steeple in the distance at the
programming center we see Bernard
getting on an escalator where we get to
see just how huge the place actually is
the scene is shot from above and
looks like there's an infinite amount of
levels going down we find out he lives
in an apartment in there and as soon as
he walks inside there's a knock at the
door it's Teresa and when she comes in
we find out they're lovers as we see
them kiss we see them in bed together
where he asked her to stay longer she
says that she can't because they never
talk anyways and then changes the
subject by mentioning the host she says
that unlike Bernard they never shut up
even when there are no people around he
explains to her that what they're doing
is trying to air correct and when they
talk to each other they are practicing
so they can appear to be more human we
see that Maeve has been brought in to be
decommissioned but LC wants to check her
out first she's annoyed with the changes
that NER that narrative made to Maeve
and decides to make some other changes
instead she decides to pump emotional
acuity in perception the tech who's
inputting the information ask if the
hosts dream because he says in her story
Maeve said she's dreams Elsie says
there's no reason to create the host to
have dreams because dreams mostly are
just memories anyways but they do give
them the concept of dreaming she says
they give them that because they need to
have the concept of nightmares just in
case their memories of what happens to
them isn't wiped clean at the end of the
night she also says that that if Maeve
has any memories it's from the people
repairing her in the body shop this is
interesting on a couple levels and I'll
get to that you know more later at the
end of the video we see Maybach in the
saloon tape talking to a newcomer who is
hanging on her every word from the same
story as he is listening to the part
where she tells him this is the new
world she passes him off to Clementine
she looks pleased and then gets into a
conversation with Teddy who's sitting at
the end of the bar she tells him that
what she really heard when she got off
the boat was a man telling her that her
[ __ ] could earn him two dollars a day
and that he would be glad to give her
30%
Teddy says that he guesses that means
that she could add lying to her list of
sins to which she replies that the only
thing wrong with the seven deadly sins
is that there aren't enough of them
Maeve says that at least what they do
isn't that bad since the men they go
with are left breathing when they're
done this implies that Teddy's role is
that of a killer which makes sense
considering he wears a black hat as they
toast each other a man shoots Teddy from
across the room and
and stands over him firing bullets into
his fallen body he's excited by the
killing and says now that's a [ __ ]
vacation as he's walking away we see
maybe in a room getting ready to sleep
where she has another memory of the
scalping scene this time she doesn't
malfunction but she just lays down down
and sort of opens and closes her eyes
and tries to fall asleep but get a
longer look at the memory and what
appears to be her having a dream we see
that in an older role she was a mother
who lived away from town with a small
daughter we see them in happier times
and then we see the fight with the
Indians they run away from the fighting
into their house where she grabs a
shotgun through the window we see that
there's a Indian warrior approaching and
when the door opens it turns out to be
the man in black which is sort of
confusing because the shot is continuous
she tries to shoot him which doesn't
work since he's a newcomer and then he
walks over with a knife to take her
Scout she uses the technique that she
told Clementine about takes a deep
breath and counts to three when she
regains consciousness she's in the body
shop where they are repairing her to the
surprise of the text she wakes up and
climbs off the gurney she grabs a
scalpel which freaks them out since they
don't seem to know what to do they try
to talk her into calming down
but she manages to leave the room she
goes outside the first building and then
goes back inside another one and she
sees that they're fixing up a bunch of
hosts all at the same time she's
terrified by what she's seeing and as
she drops to her knees the texts come in
and knock her out with an injection
through the neck they say they need to
get her out of there before anyone sees
what happened and we see that Teddy's
body's sitting in the area that where
she was looking we cut back to Delores
in bed and we see the same scenario from
the beginning of the episode she wakes
up and walks out into the yard this time
though we see she finds a gun buried
under some loose dirt that looks like it
was put there for her to find we go back
to the programming Center where Lee
Sizemore is revealing this new story he
has been working on he does a really
compelling job of presenting it and then
dr. Ford tells him that it isn't right
he explains that Lee's vision is about
him not the guest and that basically
there's no point to it and that it is
No he says the guests don't return for
the obvious things they do but instead
for the subtleties and the details he
makes a really interesting point about
how the guests come back because they
imagine they found something that no one
ever noticed before something they fall
in love with he says they're not on a
journey to find out who they are but on
a journey to get a glimpse of who they
could be as he's talking we see Logan
and William getting ready to go
somewhere and William notices Dolores
going through her routine she drops
something she bought in town and she's
putting in like a she's putting it in
her saddlebag and he walks over to pick
it up and give it back he smiles at her
and tips his hat as Logan calls him back
over what sizemore asked if there isn't
anything he likes about the new story
for just asked what size of the boots
are on one of the hosts he then see him
walking with Bernard in the field where
he ran into the boy earlier Bernard says
that the Board of Directors won't be
happy with a new store without a new
story and Fleur tells him that he has
something that he's been working on
something new something original the
episode ends with the shot of the two of
them looking at the sort of steeple
skeleton that we saw forward looking at
earlier so this episode really got me
excited about what's to come in the
first episode I was you know interested
enough but had a hard time feeling
connected with the characters that were
the hosts I guess there were too many
questions about who and what they were
to really pull me in I mean there were a
couple of really interesting occurrences
that made me want to continue watching
the series but I wasn't exactly sure how
to feel about the individual characters
that we were meeting in such like a
whirlwind fashion for this reason I
think episode 2 was a lot stronger and
I'm officially hooked into the story of
Ford Bernard and Elsie the man in black
in the gaming aspect makes a lot more
sense now
and through Maeve and Loras essenes I
think the hosts themselves have become
characters we end up feeling for plus we
get William who is new and easy to
relate to since he doesn't know what to
expect either I think the biggest thing
bringing Logan and William into the
story did was open the door to show us
how people experienced this idea of
living without limits we didn't know
enough about the man in black in episode
1 to really get what he was up to but
with William and you know we get the
idea we get to see someone who's fairly
conservative as a green newcomer someone
who's visiting for the first time with
his buddy who basically already thinks
he's an expert then we have the
he's been coming for 30 years on a quest
to level up his experience it's an
interesting comparison since we know
from interviews that came out before the
release that the show won't be based on
a rotating cast of guests at the park
here we have three different people with
3d you know distinct perceptions and
that lets us focus on dr. Ford and his
creations all in all the story moves
along nicely in Episode two and we got a
lot more information about how the park
works from behind the scenes I haven't
finished my episode 1 video yet I was
working on when the early release of
episode 2 happened so I decided to just
go ahead and get this one out of the way
first but it's gonna be coming out in
the next couple days so I hope that
you'll you know if you like this one
you'll subscribe and check that out when
it gets uploaded but as I was working on
it though I came up with three important
things that which I won't go too far
into here but the major one is that
Dolores has evolved to the point of
being able to lie to the text for
self-preservation Abernathy was
immediately commissioned after his
episode but the Loras was able to
deceive the staff so that she didn't
suffer the same fate we see how she's
continuing to discover more about
herself after they introduced the
reveries and we see that she is able to
have an effect on Mapes behavior during
their short interaction the big host
related event in this episode is that
maybe was able to wake up when she is
supposed to be in sleep mode because of
the way it went down the text who were
repairing her aren't likely to report it
which means there's a lot of potential
for a snowball effect waiting to happen
there the man in black story became a
lot more interesting even if we don't
know exactly what he does he has
knowledge enough about the park from be
from being there so many times that it
seems pretty obvious that he's going to
discover something big one thing that
stood out to me in his scenes is that he
is a different sort of invincible in the
park compared to Logan and William I
mean they all know nothing can really
happen to them but it's human nature to
react with fear whenever you know
whether you're in mortal danger or not
doesn't have to be real you're gonna be
scared just the same the man in black
knows that he literally has nothing to
fear in any situation which makes him a
lot more dangerous
I got the feeling in episode 1 that Ford
was more interested in the evolution of
his creations than he was in the
business of Westworld or the guests that
visit the
park an episode to definitely confirm
this it also makes it look like Bernard
is definitely in the same boat it's a
cool concept to think about if you've
ever created anything you know like the
way you feel a little different about it
compared to something similar that was
made by someone else imagine that
feeling applied to a complex system of
hosts who all have human traits and
personality there's a lot of potential
here related to evolution and the
connection of the creators with the
hosts I'm gonna stay out of presenting
theories as to what I think is going on
or what other people thinks going on at
this point but I'll be glad to discuss
them with you guys in the comments if
you have anything you're thinking of now
that the story is starting to take shape
I can't wait for the next episode and
I'm most interested to see what Ford has
up his sleeve
let me know in the comments what you
guys think of Westworld so far let me
know if you like the steam machine
breakdown I do or if you just click
ahead for the review and get the quick
and dirty do you have any early theories
as to how things will turn out in this
season do you think there's more going
on that's yet to be uncovered are you
feeling the show up after episode 2 or
are you still waiting to decide if it's
the next big thing please like the video
if you thought it was good and please
subscribe to my channel to help it grow
if you like Game of Thrones or mr. robot
check out the playlist I have for those
shows also I'm doing a subscriber
giveaway for my Game of Thrones fans so
check out one of my latest videos there
for details on that thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon